I have so many questions for you
first of all while you're in space you
word space for five months okay you made
almost 100 videos and these are really
good videos I mean a hundred videos you
posted pictures of birth to Twitter to
Facebook did you get any real work done
features I'm guessing it costs a fortune
to get you up there under the space
station and I picture you just like
doing selfies and a cat sauna a cats on
a piano oh and what are the roaming
charges like yeah so it's it's actually
pretty busy I did I mean I took 45
thousand pictures when I was up there
cuz I mean who wouldn't it's just the
views out the window are so great but we
work we get up at 6:00 in the morning we
work all day there's like this big like
a honey new list that comes up from the
ground you know if you got to do all
this stuff there's a big and these are
experiments you're supposed to do yeah
we run about 200 experiments on board
and it lasts till about 8 o'clock at
night so but after 8 o'clock at night
before I went to bed that's when I got
to take in pictures and everybody else
would be exhausted it's time to turn in
on the space station you've been working
all day and you say time to make my
music video yeah well I just fell asleep
every night about 1 o'clock in the
morning I just I figured I'm not gonna
be in space very long I really want to
fill the time up and get as much of it
shared back to people on earth as I
possibly could your it was your son who
convinced you to cover the David Bowie
song Space Oddity yeah and and and you
didn't want to do it at first you heard
that song you're like I don't want to do
that song well if you listen to the
original lyrics at Bowie Road I mean the
astronaut dies at the end which is
so I but I made a deal with my son why
was your son pushing his song croaks do
it he was good he was getting requests
from Twitter all over the world people
saying he gotta do Space Oddity and so
so I said if you rewrite the words so
the astronaut lives I'll do it so here
we go with the words I thought it was
nice brought it up to date I recorded
the audio and then he's like audio is
good but you're in space you need video
it's got to make the video and so one
afternoon I got the camera and I mounted
it on like a long flexible bogan arm
with the camera looking at me and and
recorded the video to go along with the
audio and send it down to him and the
space agency and they turn it into the
video that you saw yeah and it be
surprised it what a success that video
became 18 million people yeah absolute
insanity I never would have thought I
mean somehow it connected the the
original art of Bowie with the reality
of what we're doing now and it ends up
kind of mesmerizing to watch it really
came out well we have another part of
the video that I wanted to show there's
an it's an image maybe we can show it
and you can explain just what's going on
here cuz it's absolutely I'm it was
transfixed by this image and we show
that right now around the world the
Space Shuttle took these shots as it was
coming up and over the top
one of its last flights yeah and that
act was what I was talking bats way
amount to camera down in the cupola and
watch the world delay you can see the
glow of the earth with the with the edge
of the Northern Lights as you come
around I just saw my house and it was on
fire fire
the I mean there must be so many moments
where obviously this is your job you're
trained but you're sitting there and
you're watching the earth go by I had
never quite seen that angle before and
you see the entire Earth sort of
unrolling beneath you it's got to give
you a different perspective it's it's so
beautiful we go around the world sixteen
times a day you go from one side of the
US the other in about nine or ten
minutes and so you just get this this
sense of oneness of the whole thing I
went around the world about 2,500 times
so you just get a tremendous sense of
everybody being in the same place it's
unavoidable after a couple months up
there